[Music]
yeah so this uh this question's for
everybody but uh we'll start with nick
what do we think about monkey pucks
never heard of it honestly well actually
no we were talking about this off camera
i forgot you were in the room
that's why i was trying to lie to you i
tried to lie to you now but bart was
like hey nick have you heard of monkey
pox as i was walking out of the bathroom
he's like there's only like six
available and i was like
like
yeah and then it turns out to be like an
actual disease
is it right so it's not like chicken pox
it's monkey pops monkey pots what makes
it monkey is it just transmitted from a
monkey yeah yeah it's transmittable who
[ __ ] the monkey man i don't know if
this is one of the ones that's sexually
transmitted it might just be like how
many people say that pangolin came cause
i mean somebody [ __ ] the pangolin
that's why we got covered and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah
that's what the theory was they're like
cult like pangolin started covet it's
actually not bats oh yeah and someone
ate the [ __ ] out of a pangolins [ __ ] or
something
and breathed it in that's why it's a
respiratory disease respiratory dude it
only gets transmitted through foreplay
metallangus it's like no don't have sex
with it you don't have to do all that
man just go down on it like a normal
person does what do you think of the uh
so the monkey pox epidemic what's your
feelings you know i saw the pictures and
uh it's quite scary it's scary because
it's a bunch of boils
oh it looks like [ __ ] herpes on the
monkey's arm it kind of but like kind of
worse than her like that
looks like a boiled wheelhouse
yeah i don't know
i don't know anything about it but i'm
just going to be scared of it like
that's all i know do you think it's a
cause for alert at the moment
do you feel like you're how many cases
are available i think
and then limited time drop so i saw it
on abc news and i think they had like
seven in london and we just got our
first case here
it's like on the east coast here's what
it looks like or at least a part of it
oh god damn i would imagine this is
probably easier to contain than
covenant that [ __ ] looks like [ __ ]
someone questioned words
someone put boba in someone's arms yeah
i also feel like i don't know man i kind
of got like [ __ ] disease fatigue
years of marketing you know i'm like man
just
to talk about it everyone's trying to
get the new disease london's like yo we
got the new disease i'm like how many
boosters you want me to get with that
thing but it's 12 boosters so here's
something is that a child's arm
uh it doesn't
determine if your arm falls off here's a
little bit of stuff kill me now i feel
better okay so there's currently two
strains out okay only two one of them is
is super not common omicron it's uh and
then me yeah how do they name it
uh maybe it's just by monkey breeds or
something the orangutan orangutan
chimpanzee hey you got the tang man yeah
you got the tang
yeah there's so there's two there's two
uh strains one of them's super not
common one in ten people that have
gotten that have died there's been ten
people that have gone yeah but there's
another one
mainly in other countries like like
nigeria i think has a pretty high count
but they get it
like even
off season if you want to kill it
yeah what's the monkey pox season so the
other strain which is not which is more
contagious
that that's the one that's kind of
really travelling that's the omicron 100
people die from that and i think not
even
there's not even that many people that
have i mean what happens you get the
boba balls and then it goes away like is
it like chicken pox like when you get
all [ __ ] up and you're like oh dear
lord when am i gonna i can feel normal
again probably itches i bet i bet it
looks like itches hey do you know like a
lot of the uh gen z never experienced
[ __ ] chicken pox yeah oh yeah because
they hit the back seat yeah yeah yeah so
taika he gets the vaccine so he's just
never gonna get he should you should
have a vaccinated dessert i know
all of a sudden it was a teachable
moment yeah yeah
they had like chickenpox party yeah yeah
if one could get chickenpox all the rest
of their moms and dads like hey you're
going over xyz yeah they get chickenpox
they all get chicken boxes and then have
a chickenpox battle royale with the
other kids yeah yeah because like the
thing is if you didn't get chickenpox
then when you get older you get shingles
which is much more way worse i got both
you did i got both damn how do you get
both i got shingles when i was 19. what
the [ __ ] they told me it was like a
geriatric disease so i was like really
self-conscious oh that's man what did it
what was it like what was it i thought
if you had chickenpox you're not
supposed to get shingles that's what
they told me too and i have marks of
chickenpox scars all over my body
because when i was a kid my mom would be
like don't scratch them and i was like
your boy i'm gonna scratch them yeah
i have scars all over my body
uh shingles
dude like a gust of wind
would like ah it would hurt so
where did you have sugar i got it i got
it on my side right here and it's the
house i don't i think only there i think
it was because like that's when i first
started like training like mma and all
that [ __ ] and my body probably wasn't
used to it and i would train all the
time so i'm thinking like my immune
system was just really low and i just
there was a shingle somewhere on the map
yeah and the shingles got me you get it
from [ __ ] shingles
like actual [ __ ] yeah like roof shingles
boys spend a lot of time on the roof you
know
but yeah
but it hurts so bad like and it took a
while for it to recover that sucks
i remember i couldn't wear shirts
itching like a [ __ ] in
elementary school well i already itched
because of eczema but the on top of that
i had the i had the chicken pox i was it
was right here on my belly too i would
just scratch the
[ __ ] out of it like no tomorrow
oh
all over my belly so if you got monkey
pox it wouldn't really be that big
i'll probably get shingles again what
would you guys do if there's another
[ __ ] pandemic another outbreak and
then we have the lockdown and all that i
want to [ __ ] do it
no it's just happening in china right
now i'm like [ __ ] it dude
it's too too much
too much let me tell you guys what the
symptoms are for monkey pox so you can
figure out if you are getting them or
not
so uh it typically lasts two to four
weeks you start with flu-like symptoms
and swelling of the liver always flu
like [ __ ]
become [ __ ] this is fake news monkey
pog is already getting a bad review
everything is always [ __ ] flew like
what do you want is the alternative
what's your perfect thinking of the time
you just bleed out of your eyes
like i don't want everything to come on
the same because then you feel that and
you're like oh this is familiar and i
was like what the [ __ ] is all this [ __ ]
oh like you didn't realize it give it to
me in reverse make me healed with
flu-like symptoms and start me off with
the [ __ ] boils that's true because
that does come later it does come later
the bumps
i want to come first i feel like that's
the body's reaction to [ __ ] try to
burn all viruses so it's always flu-like
symptoms
i don't want to be a doctor
oh it's just a cold and you wake up like
what the [ __ ]
you guys say that it's very difficult
for it to travel human to human so how
do people get it are they [ __ ] each
other it's a really low rate of transfer
but it does so so we're okay we should
be okay then right how do kids get it i
think we're absolutely okay i think this
is just a great news thing to yeah the
monkey box why are they writing this
[ __ ] if only eight people in the whole
world have it they don't because it
looks dramatic since since 2017
nigeria's had 450 cases since but then
they get it a lot because so
vaccination does block monkey frogs but
there's a slight uh what is it called
tolerance that is built up variant so
people are starting to get it again like
a little it's just a slightly higher
number than normal got it so it's like a
stronger virus
yeah it's it's definitely well it's not
stronger in the sense that like the
fatality rate's still low but you're
actually getting it now when when i was
like you used to not be is there a
reason why what's the origin story of
the name
um it's just comes from what how it was
discovered
a monkey
like his chicken pox did it come from
chickens see that's my question thank
you like the bird flu it came from birds
came from [ __ ] birds i want to see
some birds [ __ ] sneezing and [ __ ] it
just says squeeze an ass bird get away
it's just a bird
you're like oh [ __ ] man
it's named for the animal which in which
it was discovered the disease cropped up
in 1958 among monkeys kept for research
how come we can't [ __ ] them back like a
[ __ ] chicken gets human pox or
something why are we the ones getting
[ __ ] up
like i want to give monkeys some human
pox like there you go you get [ __ ] up
straight for trade
[ __ ] sneeze over there that's true
because you know in that book guns
german steel and how europeans brought a
lot of disease it's because they lived
so closely with so much farm animals and
that's how they got contagion from all
the [ __ ]
like swine flu all that [ __ ] you know
but it came from the animals
does that mean humans were also like
they used to be healthy as [ __ ] until
[Music]
like the black death came because of the
[ __ ] um
mosquitoes or the the mosquitoes they
were yeah i mean the fleas would eat the
rats please it would they would suck the
[ __ ] disease from the rats and then
contaminate the humans and [ __ ] that was
the black death yeah bro keep animals
over there dude and who knows how many
diseases got started from
experiments gone wrong yeah like colvin
seems like that's okay i thought you
said it was from [ __ ] pangolin bro
you changing on us right now
well okay i watched this reputable
documentary called south park and
according to them i was gonna say i was
like would you say the pangolin thing i
was like i feel like that's a south park
episode
yeah it's an episodic documentary about
uh the current state of the world
and mickey mouse are [ __ ] yeah they
wasn't cheating yeah they were [ __ ]
penguins as a wild boy dude that guy got
his coat they [ __ ] the pangolin and
randy brought back kovid to the to the
world you know so you're telling me the
wuhan lab league theory is true is that
what you're saying nah it's more like a
wuhan pangolin [ __ ] theory
it's a combination of both
it's just all of it's true like in the
virus technology lab a guy [ __ ] a
pangolin on his lunch hour it was fouchy
bro check his emails man he talked about
penguins all day and then january
he's like i've been thirsting for that
penguin all
i don't know i feel like i feel like the
news and everything is just there
everyone's just in this fear cycle
because i mean like how many is that
like eight or ten people in like london
or and there's one in the us but they
they're making such a big deal of it
it's almost like we're we're we
they want to keep feeding us this and
i'm not like this mainstream news fake
news kind of person but i i am this this
level of hysteria yeah yeah of course
yeah
totally fear
mongering always gets the clicks
people are so addicted to like being
afraid and like negative [ __ ]
because when you have you know normal
news that's like have you ever seen
small town news like they run out of
[ __ ] to say right i like small ties yeah
they'll be like the fire department came
and saved the cat out of a tree today
and guess what guys halloween is
wrapping up you know what that means the
halloween parade is coming to town
and i'm like that's
tight that sounds peaceful i'm into that
you know that canyon lake community i
told you guys about it's like it's like
the country's biggest gated city and
it's over by lake elsinore it's just
it's not water right yeah it's like
around a lake where's lake elsinore
again uh orange county it's like inland
a little bit and south but they got like
i got it i got into youtube where they
have like a private youtube channel that
just talks about stuff going on in the
community and it's all positive and it
feels so nice i don't live there but i
watch the [ __ ] so cause they'll just be
like oh whatever uh auntie this lady
locally was able to make this many
cupcakes so if anybody wants one she's
got them fresh on the thing it's like
that's what life is supposed to be let's
do more of that
that makes me suspicious that sounds
like a cult
that sounds like
it's like free cooling jumping down by
the lake come through all like nice
things it's like so-and-so is doing an
art tutorial thing at her meadow so if
anyone wants to bring their easels it's
like what is this world that's
helicopter you know what yeah
he'd be like
i want to be
um post-war
1958
white boy right
six-year-old
a six-year-old white kid
in overalls on a tricycle
and i'm in this new neighborhood the new
suburb in in late 1950s right leave it
to beaver stuff leave it to viewers
style yeah i kind of lit not i love lucy
but later on i love lucy right it's like
you know you have your mom that stays
home makes [ __ ] cookies for you and
your friends you have a slingshot in
your back pocket man comes by everyone
knows the milkman look man
he's not [ __ ] your mom yeah this is
before america turns into [ __ ] yeah yeah
you [ __ ] throw a rock at a chinese
person or something
good old days the good old days you know
you have to really bank on being white
yeah you gotta yeah in this fantasy
you're
you're a six-year-old blonde white kid
an aryan child it's the uh with overalls
in the striped shirt you know what i
mean that's the eternal question that
there's always a roadblock when they ask
you as an asian when they go hey if you
could time travel back to any period
where would you want to go it's like
i'll be killed in any other period big
dynasty daughter i would be instantly
murdered
unless you are the royal of that era
you